nicht erschrecken ich habe für dieses
Video jetzt mal kurz die Kamera
umgestellt und sagt mir doch gerne wie
ihr das findet frontal gut oder lieber
seitlich schreibt mir gerne in die
Kommentare das war jetzt ein bisschen
Organisation jetzt geht es weiter mit
dem Video dieses Paket kam einfach aus
Böblingen Böblingen ist im Schwabenland
und in böbling bin ich ganz oft wegen
Timo meinem
Verlobten also da kommen seine Eltern
her falls Sie das noch nicht jetzt
gecheckt ich bin so froh dass dieses
Paket pünktlich gekommen ist es gibt näm
viele adventskalenderanbieter die erst
so zum Ende November liefern und weil
mir das immer zu spät ist weil ich sie
ja vorher testen möchte vor allen
anderen habe ich lilan le auf Instagram
geschrieben ob sie meine Bestellung
vielleicht vorziehen können sie haben es
gemacht vielen Dank an dieser
Stelle ach so bevor ich noch zu auft
Lillian Leim sage dieses Video ist
natürlich nicht gesponsert und jetzt
alle dieses Video ist natürlich nicht
gesponsert ich habe den Kalender selbst
gekauft hatte nur gefragt ob sie den mir
schneller schicken
können vielen Dank liebe Vanessa kein
Problem welcome to Lillian LME family oh
ist ist alles cute ein Mini
Adventskalender und auf der Rückseite
steht was man an dem Tag machen soll
heiße Schokolade trinken abdancen zu
einem Weihnachtssong das sind harte
Aufgaben wenn man so ein bisschen
Inspiration brauch
cute hier haben wir in Papiertüten
verpackte Türchen muss mir den erstmal
hier
sortieren
dre Tage später ich bin ehrlich mit euch
Lillian lime kannte ich nicht ich habe
es erst durch euch kennengelernt als ihr
mir den Adventskalender vorgeschlagen
habt ja wie soll man lilienlim
beschreiben ne super cute ich finde auf
der Website sagen sie schon gut es sind
kunterbunte Schreibwaren und so ein
Schreibwaren Adventskalender hat auch
echt was cooles big big habe ich gekauft
2000 € das ist ein Preis für
Schreibwaren nicht schlecht das ist
Luxus das kauft man nicht das gönnt man
sich und der Kalender soll einen Wert
von 230 € haben ich glaube das ist eine
relativ kleine Firma wir gucken einfach
mal 210 € ich meine ich gebe auch 200 €
für beautykalender aus und am Ende ist
es auch nur Make-up
deswegen wir sind sehr
gespannt wir fangen an mit tüchen Nummer
ein wie wollt schreib war hab ich
bekommen mhm ich verstehe ehrlich gesagt
diesen Sticker nicht wohin ich den mir
kleben soll moments of 2024 in Türchen
Nummer 1 ist eine 30 day Challenge für
was auch immer zusammen mit dem Sticker
gehe ich jetzt mal davon aus dass es für
den Januar sein soll weil zum Neujahr
macht man sich immer neue Vorsätze das
Fin ich ein bisschen dünn gerade fürs
erste Türchen zum Ende hin ja vielleicht
schon also ich finde es ist eine ganz
nette Idee aber zum 1 Dezember mache ich
mir doch noch überhaupt keine Gedanken
zu meinem Neujahrsvorsatz es ist das
erste Türchen wir judgen mal noch nicht
bookbit Cover im Namen des Volkes
verkünde ich folgendes Urteil Türchen
Nummer
2 hier ist das wofür wir gekommen
sind Stifte oh sind die süß mit diesen
Stiften kann man wirklich sein
pastelltraum Leben das ist nur die Frage
schreibt ihr gut mein Name oh schreiben
die gut manche Kugelschreiber haben was
an sich dass die viel besser schreiben
als andere und dass man dadurch auch
besser schreibt wow als Beweis ich kann
schreiben ich hoffe dass hier viele
bunte Büroartikel sein werden denn ich
ziehe mit meinem Büro um ich stell mir
mein Büro so richtig schön bunt vor und
da passen dann solche Stifte perfekt
dieser Kalender soll einen wahren Wert
von ungefähr 10 € Pro Türchen haben und
ob das stimmt finden wir tüchenchen 3
raus ich muss eine Sache mal testen also
bei Alibaba kostet so ein Stift ungefähr
60 70 Cent das sind dann ungefähr 2,80 €
weil ich frag mich wo die ja sonst
herkommen sollten Türchen Nummer 3
oh da braucht sie die to-d Liste das ist
sogar ein eigenes Design das haben die
sogar selbst gedruckt hier steht Lillian
Leme drauf ich bin ein To-Do Listen
ultra wenn es darum geht es selbst
aufzuschreiben ich kann es gar nicht mit
dem Handy und daran denken dass da noch
irgendwas drin steht muss es irgendwo
liegen haben durchstreichen können immer
wieder drauf zurückgreifen können und
schaut doch mal wie toll das zusammenpst
super 210
€ t
Nummer Sticker mit eigenem
stickerdign Nummer
5 okay Stopp also dieses Türchen ist so
weird erstmal war das hier drin Love
Letters friends lilan Limes also so ein
Umschlag und jetzt sind da so Karten
drin
Zuckerwatte irgendwas mit dem Workout
für ein Arsch dann soll man hier
irgendwas drauf schreiben was ich
irgendwie komisch finde weil das so ein
ganz komische Oberfläche dafür ist life
gives you lemons cherries und wir
vergessen natürlich nicht die 30y day
Challenge und eine Liste mit Rezepten
die man sich aufschreiben kann also
keine Rezepte sondern einfach nur was
man so gerne ist weiß ich nicht diger
ich glaube was mir hier jetzt gerade
auch nicht so passt ist dass das alles
so sommerlich ist so sommerliche Designs
ich meine ich bin gerade im Dezember vor
mir sind jetzt vier Monate Winter die
sehr hart werden wir machen weiter es
ist Nikolaus Türchen Nummer 6 gehen zu
unserem
Adventskalender Santa Claus hier gibt's
wenigstens eine weihnachtliche Postkarte
schön und drei Büroklammern mit
Tannenbaum ich fin sehr cute es ist sehr
süß Türchen Nummer 7 na schaut mal an
goldenes Herzen washi tape und ein
goldenes washi tape ja kann man zu
Weihnachtszeit immer gut
gebrauchen ja was klebe ich denn
jetzt gutes washi tape für 10 € das
Türchen zwei Washi Tapes wei ich muss
das T Nummer
a oh das ist schwer choose love
happiness und Rainbows macht mich an
dieser Stelle kaputt Notes also ein Blog
auch für den Schreibtisch wo man sich
Notizen machen kann ja ist doch schön
natürlich ein bisschen blöd jetzt mal
wenn ich jetzt so an meinen Schreibtisch
denke wenn beides so so ein Blauton ist
wäre natürlich toll wenn so verschiedene
Farben hätte aber trotzdem siehth toll
zusammen aus das liegt dann so auf
meinem Schreibtisch nebeneinander t
Nummer ne
oh ja es ist wichtig man muss sich alle
Sachen notieren und jetzt habe ich ein
Notizblock jetzt habe ich eine
Checkliste und eine To-Do Liste na gut
das muss man ja alles auch
differenzieren life is short make it
sweet ach guck mal da haben sie sich ihr
eigenes Design auf dem Bleistift drucken
lassen brauner Bleistift und das ist so
im
chocolate Design die Checkliste was ist
jetzt der Unterschied zwischener
Checkliste und einer To-Do Liste okay
nee eine Checkliste beim Packen da
brauchen wir eine Checkliste ja eine
Checkliste und todooliste sind schon
unterschiedliche Sachen F mich ein
bisschen wieder als ob ich didleblätter
sammeln würde bei diesen ganzen bunten
Blöcken aber das hat eine tolle Qualität
und einen tollen Druck und das kommt
sogar mit dem Bleistift Nummer ze ach
guck mal ich bin so begeistert von
diesem Adventskalender dass ich eben
gerade sogar vergessen habe zu erwähnen
dass das neunte das beste Türchen ist
dann ist jetzt wohl das zehnte das beste
Türchen okay ich bin jetzt erstmal
verwirrt music Bundle ist jetzt hier ein
iPod drin oder noch eine weitere
Checkliste
bin ich nicht die Zielgruppe na doch
eigentlich schon Songs different m hier
kann man sowas über Musik ausfüllen viel
interessanter finde ich jetzt diese zwei
Blöcke mal wieder bleib nett bleib
einfach nett ich bin ich bleibe nett
reiben Sie die Wut in die Wüste keine
Ahnung in welcher Lebenssituation ich
schriftlich meinenvorite aufschreiben
würde und dann schreiben würde was für
ein Genre der ist welche besten Songs
der hat in welcher Situation ich diesen
dieses Songs gerne höre und ob ich schon
mal auf dem Konzert war hier können wir
uns Gedanken über einen einzelnen Song
machen ich habe so ein bisschen gehofft
dass ich was für mein Büro bekommen aber
schade schade ich habe noch nie darüber
nachgedacht aufzuschreiben wie ich zu
irgendeiner Musik stehe Nummer 11 ah das
finde ich ja süß diese Karten die man
dann an so ein Weihnachts Geschenk dran
machen kann ich finde die runden so ein
Weihnachtsgeschenk noch mal ganz
besonders ab und hier hat man gleich
eine kleine Schnur dazu um das richtig
zu befestigen a und einmal in
Groß
matorn
matorn hast du gerade wieder dran
gedacht oder wie
ja du Gott es kommt erst langsam bei dir
an ne stellt sich für mich halt wieder
die Frage ist das ein 10 € Türchen ja
ich glaube ich unterschätze auch an
dieser Stelle wie teuer schreib war sind
ja ich glaube ich unterschätze es
einfach wisst ihr es fällt mir auch echt
schwer gemeine Sachen zu sagen wenn man
so eine Karte bekommt vielen Dank liebe
Vanessa WIS ihr und dann soll ich sagen
das gefällt mir jetzt ja gar nicht das
ist
schwer was ist das Türchen Nummer
12 soll das Popcorn sein soll das Käse
sein ich glaub das soll Popcorn sein
aber warum ist das so Geld poppin das
ist Popcorn cool und dann kann man das
hier so Boom ist ein süßer Bleistift Pop
stell mir vor wie ich so ein ultra
Ernstes business meeting habe und dann
mit meinem
popcornstift ja das noti ich mir ganz
kurz gute Idee ach das ja das ist
Popcorn Popcorn
13 es geht schon wieder los dieses Mal
haben wir das Movie Bundle nicht das
Popcorn bndle warum ist das alles auf
Englisch sind die international
moviead Karten für eine Movie Night
super cute wenn man so eine Movie Night
bei sich zu Hause machen möchte und dann
movie Challenge ja dann gibt's wieder so
zwei Sachen die man ausfüllen kann eine
Watchlist und movie Review also
vielleicht wenn man mal wirklich eine
Movie Night macht und dann jedem so ein
Zettel gibt und jeder soll den Film
bewerten und so aber ich verstehe nicht
dann dieses aufschreiben weil man würde
das ja eher dann sagen ja ich fand den
Film gut ich gebe ihm zwei von fün
Sternen oder Popcorn was passiert mit
diesem Zettel landet der in meiner
Schublade gucke ich ihn mir irgendwann
mal an warum sollte ich mir meine eigene
Bewertung über einen Film angucken
schenke ich die jemanden warum sollte
ich jemanden meine Bewertung über ein
Film
schenken 14 ich bin nicht die Zielgruppe
glaube ich ich glaube wenn ich 13 wäre F
ich das cooler jetzt ist wieder ein
Bleistift drin mit Wünschen die ich
aufschreiben soll twinkle twinkle little
star ich bin nicht die Zielgruppe Nummer
15 das liebe ich wieder das ist genau
das was ich brauche Radiergummis die
aussehen wie Früchte in meiner Schale
von mutella Mio oh mein Gott ach ich
bräuchte noch mehr Radiergummi Obst dann
liegt das so drin
16 Gingerbread kisses und Christmas
wishes Hot Chocolate season the magic of
winter leere Notizbücher finde ich ja
schön weil es ja deren Design ist und
eigene Illustration Problem mit diesen
Heften und ich will nicht überall das
Haar der Suppe suchen aber das Problem
mit dies Heften die Oberfläche fühlt
sich ganz furchtbar an ich weiß nicht
was das für ein Druck sein soll oder was
für ein Papier das ist oh ich hass
das dieses glatte feste ich kann nicht
beschreiben es ist so ich habe gerade
das Gefühl damit dass ich das angefasst
habe habe ich an der Tafel gekratzt
Nummer
17 ich dachte ehrlich ich s wie das ist
ich dachte ich krieg hier Stifte
Radiergummi Mappen ich krieg hier
Checklisten die wollen wirklich dass man
was abhackt eine shoppinglist
18 they did it
again Podcast bndel ich habe mir ja
nicht nur Gedanken über das was ich an
Musik das eigentlich das Spotify Bundle
ah ne da gibt's keine Filme dodle und
Listen eigentlich eine coole Idee ich
höre tatsächlich Podcast aber immer wenn
ich was wirklich mache also ich setze
mich nie hin und höre einen Podcast ich
muss dann immer aufräumen oder so das
ist für mich die perfekte Zeit ich
aufräume dann kann ich meine ganzen
Podcasts hören dann räume ich auch voll
viel auf weil ich will halt weiterhören
aber so als allgemeiner doodleblog ist
das halt auch nett beim Telefonieren
oder wenn man halt mal kurz ja sich dann
doch hinsetzt und den Podcast hört my
alltime favorite episodes ich habe jetzt
keine Episoden die ich bei Podcast
besonders gut finde also ja klar es gab
mal Momente wo ich richtig doll lachen
musste oder die ich total cool und
spannend fand aber es gibt jetzt nicht
so oh Folge 210 ey das ist die beste die
hö ich mir immer wieder an also ich
finde die Idee ja ganz cool aber in der
Umsetzung ich würde doch niemals wisst
ihr hinsetzen und und aufschreiben warum
ich ein Podcast gerne höre und warum
diese Folge meine Lieblingsfolge ist bin
da nicht so für Nummer
19 ey komm wirklich ich habe mir Stifte
gewünscht aber warum wollte denn ein
Mensch
acht Kugelschreiber in Pastell acht
Stück eine achtköpfige Familie bräuchte
acht
Stück V allem dies Design habe ich doch
schon oh es tut mir so leid es tut mir
so leid Nummer 20 ach cute ja komm sowas
habe ich mir gewünscht da geht noch was
in unsere gemüseschüssel eine
Avocado oh das ist so ein süßes
Radiergummi und noch ein
Notizbuch die Leute die das gemacht
haben die haben sehr viele Gedanken die
sie aufschreiben müssen könnte ich von
lilen lime das Podcast Bundle als
Adventskalender Bundle kriegen dann kann
ich immer meine Bewertungen für den
Kalender auf so Zettel schreiben
21 ich dachte das wä schon wieder
Popcorn ich habe nur das gesehen und
dachte so oh ja so sieht Popcorn aus
aber es ist ein
Regenbogen ist ein sehr unpraktisches
radiigummi also sehr süß und so aber
damit kann man ja nicht radieren
Würfelspiel und natürlich ein Bleistift
jazi oder Kniffel ist das okay he es ist
ein Würfelspiel wo sind die Würfel wo
sind die
Würfel
22 ich schieb es auf mich selbst ich
habe mich nicht vorher genug mit
dieser Firma beschäftigt noch eine
Shoppingliste für skincare
herceh Makeup body ich habe das Gefühl
so viele Produkte von denen sind einfach
nicht zu zu Ende gedacht ich muss
einkaufen gehen also schreibe ich mir
eine Shoppingliste hier ist unterteilt
in skincare Haircare Make-up und Body
wie viele Produkte kaufe ich denn auf
einmal nach also wenn eine Sache leer
geht dann hole ich ja diese eine Sache
nach weil ich brauche ja diese eine
Sache aber ich hätte ja nie eine Liste
von Dingen die ich bräuchte oh mein Gott
okay na ja das muss ich mir kurz mal
angucken hier kann man sich mal ein
richtigen Plan zu seiner herkehr machen
wann soll ich eine Maske auftragen wann
soll Dings waschen blablabla wenn man
Zeit richtig machen möchte und sage ich
mal s Plan erstellen will das finde ich
tatsächlich auch gar nicht so schlecht
es ist gut sich ein Plan zu machen wie
man die skincare macht also z.B manche
Produkte soll man ja nur ein bis zweimal
die Woche benutzen und dann benutzt man
andere an anderen Tagen und sich das
aufzuschreiben ist ja eine gute Idee
damit man einfach gucken kann ah heute
ist Mittwoch ah heute mache ich diese
Creme drauf deswegen finde ich das gar
nicht schlecht und auch dass es mehrere
gibt weil man ja das immer wieder
umstellt was neues ausprobiert und sich
eine neue Routine überlegt ich verstehe
noch nicht ganz so wie das hier
aufgebaut ist aber ich denke mal wenn
man sich damit mehr befasst dann wird
das wahrscheinlich was aber das schon
wieder ein Skin diary wo ich sage wie
meine Haut ist was ich so gegessen habe
ob ich schlaf hatte wie ich drauf war na
ja das macht man jeden Tag ja gut nee
man kann dann auch aber ey sorry das ist
aber auch so ein Produkt pimples und so
das ist für Teenager jetzt habe ich
meinen letzten Beweis dieser Kalender
diese Produkte alles hier ist für
wirklich ab 10 bis 14 dann aber auch
wiederum komisch dass es auf Englisch
ist wie viele zehnjährige können so gut
englisch the was very competent prepared
23 das ist doch niedlich ein Tagesplan
das werde ich mal versuchen zu benutzen
weil das brauche ich auch mal so alles
zusammengefasst dass ich am Abend mir
einen Plan für den nächsten Tag erstelle
eine To-Do Liste habe meine Termine
aufschreibe ja dass ich so morgens immer
mal gucken kann ohne jetzt alles
zusammammeln zu müssen und weil wir
Notizen machen so sehr lieben können wir
hier auch noch mal zweimal Notizen
aufschreibenürlich Nummer 24 seid ihr
ready glaube nicht ne bessere Oberfläche
das hat's auf jeden Fall Kugelschreiber
Nummer ne und so ein Notizbuch boah es
tut mir so leid Neil ich glaube das sind
sehr nette Menschen die da auch so
hinter stecken und sich da was so
überlegt haben aber es ist überhaupt
nicht meins wir sind zwei
organisationsverrückte Studentin namens
Isabella und Johanna Zi junge Frauen die
den Kopf voller Kreativität haben mal
sind die Ideen interessant gut oder auch
total verrückt so ist auch dieses
herzenprjekt standen uns beide verbindet
die Liebe zum Zeichnen gestalten und
entwerfen schon immer träumen wir davon
unsere eigene Produkte in der Hand
halten zu dürfen mit lillien Lime haben
wir diesen Traum wahr werden lassen 3,90
€ kostet ein so ein Kugelschreiber
manche Produkte fand ich gut mit manchen
konnte ich halt nicht so viel anfangen
ich weiß aber auch nicht so richtig die
Zielgruppe ob ich nicht wirklich schon
zu alt dafür bin also ich hätte zu Hause
habe ich mir immer irgendwelche Sachen
aufgeschrieben und so und wenn ich dann
so meine Musiklisten zusammengetrag
Tagen hätte so das hätte mir schon
gefallen aber wie gesagt so mit 12
Jahren mit 30 nicht mehr was mich aber
jetzt verwirrt ist z.B jetzt auch der
Preis vom Adventskalender ja ich weiß
die Produkte ich habe jetzt mal online
geguckt haben so alle ihre Kosten und
das ist alles handverpackt das ist ein
kleines Startup das ist jetzt kein
großes Unternehmen aber passt es dann
mit dem Alter ich habe das Gefühl es ist
an junge Leute gerichtet aber junge
Leute können nicht für 210 € sich ein
Adventskalender kaufen einzige rich Kids
also wenn ich jetzt so eine Zielgruppe
für diesen Adventskalender erstellen
müsste dann wärden es von 10 bis 14 und
die Eltern sind reich und dann macht
dieser Kalender Sinn neuen
Kugelschreiber wirklich ist echt
schwierig ich meine die Konkurrenz bei
Adventskalendern ist so groß und
vielleicht muss nicht jeder ein
Adventskalender rausbringen wisst ihr
was ich meine vielleicht ist es auch
okay wenn man es einfach nicht macht
weil der Onlineshop ist süß und wenn ich
mir ein Kugelschreiber so bestellen
wollen würde dann könnte ich mir den ja
dort bestellen aber was man dann hier
alles so an Blöcken und so und Stiften
bekommt ist dann ist dann vielleicht ja
zu viel auch so bis dann Leute tschüss
es tut mir so leid Lil Leim